you've put together an application of
like people to have casual sex with you
I think yeah and also dating yeah and
also dating in a relationship I'd love
to so what is in that application
because like
you know
um
I'm sure there's a quite a lot of people
that would like to date you or to sleep
with you but finding the person I mean
it depends what your goals I guess
relationship would be an open
relationship for you yes right like for
me I guess it's more intensely selective
because it's like a monogamous
relationship and a committed one like
like like I'm I'm swinging for the yeah
like for like long term I'm not I'm not
like weirdly obsessed with long term but
it's like you just I would love to have
one girl for the rest of my life but
finding that I feel like applications
will not get to that I feel like there's
some aspect of the magic of the the
Serendipity of it of meeting people in
strange places and so on I I just I
personally have noticed that like Fame
has not made that process easier but I
mean like if you could you know if
there's two rooms and one of them it's
like a random population of hot women
and the other one is random population
of hot women but all of them definitely
are monogamous and are looking for a
long-term relationship yeah like which
room would you rather go into
like if you're looking for a mate yeah
well but see I guess my preferences are
more this this is a really strong point
but my preferences are represent the
majority probably right because don't
most women want monogamous relationships
yeah so like it's I'm okay with either
option
because like statistically speaking
right but like we can apply it to like a
bunch of other things yeah and I'm just
this is just a problem if you have like
high if you have a high volume to filter
through and you like you don't know like
it's a good like initial filter
like you can take it from like a
thousand people to 20 people and then go
to dates with them but the filter is so
anti-romantic like what
this is true this is not the Romantic
narrative that uh that you're very proud
I feel like how did how did you two meat
well she passed the three filters I set
up
and uh
I mean but that's also but also can you
put into a survey the things that you're
interested in
yeah I mean I definitely think about
this a lot with hiring like like teams
engineers and so on
but with engineers
you're okay losing truly special
Engineers because you have to filter
because there's like thousands of
applications like it feels like
it feels like I worry that you would
miss the thing that actually
because so much of his chemistry so much
of it it's like the magic you know the
thing is you're missing it anyway like
yeah you're missing oh you can just run
it and then in addition try some of
those people
and then they didn't go on the dates
that you were going to go on with anyway
regardless it's just the thing that
helps like pull someone out of the crowd
like this I I dated a guy from my survey
I'd ran the survey I assigned Point
values each of the questions yeah I
wanted a date with like the top couple
people and then one of them I was like
and I'm still dating him to this day it
was awesome
and I would never I never would have
gone on a date with him without the
survey can you can you if from memory or
we can look it up do you remember what
kind of questions were on the survey I
asked a couple different categories I
asked about like basic life stuff so
like what kind of relationships like
monogamy versus polyamory like do you
want kids you know like where you want
to live like basic things that you need
to be compatible and then I asked like
sexual compatibility like various
preferences and then I had a section
about like personality like what a PR I
try to ask questions that would do the
most effective filtering so like what
are ways that like I can't give give
people what they need that like maybe
they really want like I don't really I'm
not very outdoorsy and it's just very
common a lot of people like being
outdoorsy so I asked the question like
how much do you value someone else that
you're dating being outdoorsy have they
marked yes I was like okay we probably I
should probably download man but doesn't
polyamory make that really difficult
because can't they find somebody for the
outdoorsy stuff yeah they could I mean
this doesn't like but if you're going to
have somebody it's like nicer to have
them be more compatible than less but
you're a little bit like in terms of
sexual compatibility you're able to
like you're self-aware enough to know
what preferences you have like you can I
think so I think that one helped a lot
with the escorting like the escorting
helped a lot with knowing my preferences
but there's like out of the the Giant
pool of different preferences you
haven't like a subset that's clearly
defined for you
okay like like Dominus submissive yeah
Power Dynamic stuff
okay in the not just sexual blind
relationship too like that was that in
the survey I don't like paradigms in
relationships I'm not defining them in
like making it clear in a survey like
asking a question about power dynamics
in a relationship
I don't think I asked about power
dynamics in relationships okay because I
just assume most people don't there's a
lot of things that are kind of like most
people don't you're putting together a
survey a systematic server to understand
compatibility
wouldn't power dynamics inside of
relationships that naturally emerge
often be part of the question or or is
that is that hard to question because it
naturally emerges the thing is like a
lot of questions sort of overlap in
demographic and if you're making a
survey you want to have the minimum
possible questions that give the maximum
possible like filtering information so
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute but that purpose of
that survey wasn't to do a good research
study it was to select one subject that
you could take so that's part of what's
is good like you want to most
efficiently filter out because one like
you get more people taking the survey
the fewer questions you have which is
good for finding a mate like if you have
5 000 men take the surveys better than
one thousand men don't you want men that
that would be patient enough and
dedicated enough yeah but like what if
you're like a high-powered man who's
like on his lunch break yeah right so
it's like it's just like a billionaire
is too busy just flipping through yeah
and the guy that I did was was that he
took the survey he was waiting for the
piece to come to come out of the oven
and so it was important that it was
short
are literally pizza coming he's
literally waiting for pizza and he saw
the things like I guess I'll just fill
out the survey really fast and changed
our lives so romantic I I it's for me
this is my kind of Romance I'm really
into it but but you could it could be
efficient with surveys by like making
sure your questions don't overlap so for
example if somebody's very polyamorous
they're very unlikely to be interested
in like a traditional like man Works in
like and out and the job in the woman
stays home and raises the kids kind of
relationship because probably people
just generally don't do that and so if
I'm asking about polyamory it's sort of
kind of already covers the thing and so
if I have a whole bunch of questions
like I can kind of like triangulate a
bunch of implicit kinds of questions
that I haven't directly asked about
so this is why I didn't ask directly
about power dynamics because like from
the rest of the questions that are in my
survey like I think pretty accurately
predict whether or not you're going to
be interested in power dynamics but I'm
afraid yeah like I'm trying to think as
you're talking I get it it's that's
really interesting that you did that
also maybe not for the effectiveness of
finding a partner but for just exploring
the actual the process
of of human sexuality of of like the
search this this complicated
optimization process we're all engaging
in on the landscape of happiness that
seems to be uh this
um
not even a differentiable function it's
it's a giant non-linear mess
okay but like for me I don't think I'll
be able to design that survey I would
like bias it too strongly like um
I'll probably prefer women
that have read Dostoevsky or something
like that like there'll be a filter for
me right yeah but like that's a horrible
filter because there's a lot of like
there's a lot of amazing people that
have never they don't give a about
reading or they don't give a about
reading Russian literature or they don't
give a about but they're amazing
and passionate and creative and all in
some other dimension that you might
completely Miss but you're like because
I wonder if there's any basically you're
saying compatibility like hard lines
that you know statistically is just
going to be an issue yeah I mean you
wait this a lot more yeah but there's
also like preferences like if you have a
woman who's totally equal and she's read
the thing that you like for she was
another woman who's also identical but
like she hasn't read the thing that you
like like you probably like very
slightly prefer the one well you don't
know what the identity yes yes but like
you can't through survey get the
identical like you don't know sure but
you can kind of like like do a whole
bunch of weight so like the person that
like I ended up going on a date with he
and did not answer like correctly to a
lot of the survey questions but he
didn't have to like he was just overall
overall the weights were like he just
tended to be more in the direction was
there a text-based fill in like a survey
but like uh sorry a paragraph like no
you want to avoid that if you're dealing
with like large amounts of data no why
not because you have to fill oh oh
interesting interesting like I'm I'm
different because like first of all you
do keyword searches okay that's all you
do you can do machine learning models
that like like uh first of all you can
do you could do like crude metrics like
the length
that's a good point of how long they've
written right
and it could flag certain things yeah
it's actually pretty easy to like I've
I've looked at like for hiring I've
looked at like thousands of applications
really quickly like you can really the
the human brain is really interesting
especially
um
like if you visually highlight certain
information for yourself like keywords
or again with machine learning models
like sentiment you can you can highlight
different parts that will catch your eye
better than not and I I can go through
just a huge number of applications are
you telling me I can use if I learn
machine learning I can process dating
survey applications better yes no like
textual yeah like I can like have them
write things in like it's like a new way
of that would be yeah it's a really good
incentive I think that would so it's a
really nice aspect
of text input like long form text input
multiple long form text input based on
an interestingly phrased question is you
get to learn how to make a better survey
I think you would appreciate that like
you start to see how they're actually
interacting with these questions like I
asked certain questions like um just to
see how people think is it better to
work smart or better to work hard
or
um is it uh ever okay to betray a close
friend
like I'll ask like questions like this
that don't really have a right answer
but I just want to see how they think or
is uh truth more important than loyalty
yeah
and and I get their long-form answer you
get like and you get to see the
reasoning process yeah yeah like what
they it reveals so much not just about
the person but about the kind of
questions I want I should be asking that
has nothing to do with truth or loyalty
but like how to get a good engineer with
like very specific questions but I think
it's really useful to get text input I I
have done text input usually with beta
surveys so I usually do beta service
before I do the real survey what's the
beta like I do like a shorter version or
it depends on what I'm doing but like a
different version of the survey that I
have people take before I release I use
the information from the initial survey
to inform the questions that I ask in
the real survey and I haven't actually
in recently but I used to do a lot of
like the text-based questions to see for
similar although I don't think I relied
it on it quite as heavily and if I
introduce machine learning things would
be a lot more efficient I love that
you're also doing like you're writing
scripts and stuff like you're doing
you're doing something like uh like
statistical analysis or using python
also yeah I had to Learn Python for
and the best reason to learn machine
learning is to solve actual like
problems I can't be motivated I'm just
not motivated to learn something unless
there's an actual curiosity I have and I
have to learn it and to solve it I was
trying to avoid learning coding for so
long but eventually it was my data set
became too large I couldn't work with it
with anything else so
oh python it is you know what's also an
interesting data set that you're
probably interested in a little bit is
like Twitter itself right I don't know
if you've I've played with the Twitter
API a lot can you just get
the download the I'm just I'm stuttering
now because download the Twitter you
download Twitter no there's a lot of
Twitter Twitter so Twitter is a social
network with a bunch of people that are
interacting a lot like there's like I
don't know the number is insane the
number of interactions but there's
different
ways to interact to get data from
Twitter there's streams you can look at
it depends what you're interested in you
can do uh results for searches you can
look at individual tweets and get entire
which to me is super interesting the
entire tree of different conversations
or the replies which might be very
interesting for you because like
it's not
I it's it's much harder to ask rigorous
questions which you do with your polls
but you could see like how divisive
certain things are yeah the calibrators
to figure out like exactly what
questions you should be asking yeah and
also highlight interesting anecdotal
things when like two people freak out at
each other and just argue like a thread
that goes on for like a thousand
messages that you might never be even
aware is happening because you're like
because Twitter doesn't like surface
that like it would be Twitter doesn't
make it easy for you to like visualize
what the hell is going on even with your
social network like uh like if you post
something that's controversial that gets
a large amount of attention it you can't
clearly visualize everything that's
going on yeah like it's it's very
it's a blurry amorphous like you're just
kind of looking through the fog at
different replies and the kind of it's
uh yeah so the API they have like like
graphs of networks they have the data
for the graphs yeah so you can
reconstruct yourself yeah and then you
have different levels of access in terms
of how many queries you can do
that's really cool and now because
there's like uh Elon
um there's a lot of sort of
revolutionary stuff happening at Twitter
I think
you could literally sort of push for
Innovation there like there's aggressive
Innovation happening so in terms of uh
requesting stuff for the API you could
do all that kind of stuff I think
Twitter is just a fascinating platform
for the as cliche as it sounds for
studying
for me it's interesting what makes for a
healthy conversation that term has been
used but it's interesting how
conversation to me is fascinating how
conversations break down
and not like how like the virality of
drama
or conflict or disagreement how that
evolves when a large number of people
are involved when a large number of this
no no
misinterpretation of of statements is
involved in text-based with some
anonymity thrown in like I feel like
there's a lot of studies that can be
done there I mean Twitter's probably not
great at it right as it stands no
because it's like necessarily short you
can quote trade things out of context et
cetera but but we should understand that
right yeah at a scale at a large scale
you should be able to uh study that kind
of thing which oh yeah what was your
casual sex uh survey I actually haven't
looked at in a while
I just asked people about a whole bunch
of fetishes because you don't want to be
obvious about yours because when people
are going to hijack it to try to tell
you that they like what you like so you
want to be obscure so how do you design
a survey where you're testing for a
thing but you're still obscure about the
thing you're trying to ask about so you
still see it as a survey yeah yeah like
an application
because you I think you tweeted saying
like I'm thinking of just like showing
up to San Francisco and saying
is anybody open for casual sex stuff
like this am I misremember maybe
escorting I'm not sure oh for escalated
which is similar like I kind of use
escorting as the way to have casual sex
now